hi so for the first video of 2024 I
wanted to create a video that's
dedicated to different types of study
techniques so over the course of doing
my MERS and also now the PHD I learned
different type of techniques that really
work for me and I do want to caveat this
by saying that I do think everyone has a
different type of studying approach that
works for them but I kind of wanted to
give you these techniques and maybe some
of them will work for you so let's get
straight into it so I divided it up into
five different chapters so first of all
fictionalize your life then Creative
Study techniques optimize your work
space and digital space morning routine
for productivity and finally different
motivation strategies so first of all
for the fictionalize your life this is
maybe a little bit strange idea but I
kind of like to visualize certain study
tasks or certain things that I have to
do as chapters within a novel so the
idea is that you if you could rewrite a
novel with all the rewards and viewing
yourself as the main character which
would be the next steps in the chapter
how would your character act in certain
situations which values does your
character live up to and I think by kind
of viewing yourself as studying or doing
a PhD or researching as a character
within a fictionalized novel you can
kind of see what you would like your
character to live up to and I think this
works especially well if you yourself
read a lot of books like I do I
especially enjoy reading fiction books
for example Brandon serson is a fiction
writer that I really enjoy or lately I
also have read the poppy Wars and I
think through identifying which these
characters and also placing some of
their values on your own fictionalized
character you can kind of see what for
you is really motivating so then the
second tips that I want to give are
Creative Study techniques so this is
really when I was in a period that I had
to memorize a lot I think memorizing and
learning the skill how to memorize is
really important when you're studying so
one of the things I always do is if I
have study material I create kind of a
narrative story structure out of it and
then I re-explain the study material to
myself so for example if I have to learn
a concept in physics about atoms I would
re-explain the entire chapter as a story
chapter to myself and that really works
to restructure The Narrative and also to
Truly Deeply understand what is being
said another thing I always do is I use
a lot of visualization and diagram
techniques to make the story Visual and
this is especially if you're really a
visual thinker so when I close my eyes I
can kind of see these images up in front
of me and then through looking at these
images and through explaining these
images I kind of understand all the
concepts better and especially if you
work with technical Concepts this is a
really good tip I think of course um I
also used the memonic palace when I was
learning numbers or these kind of things
so I didn't do it as strictly as for
example in this book where they really
explain how memorization experts do it
what I did more is I just have within my
room a certain root right and alongside
the root that I take in in my room so in
my mind I would Place certain things
that I need to memorize in order and
then if you rewalk the room you can Reem
these things and this is really good if
you have to remember some kind of
narrative structure for example or
giving a presentation so then um tips
number three are optimize your workspace
and digital space this is definitely
something I relearned during my PhD I
think it was a little bit less important
during the Masters cuz I would just kind
of study everywhere but now doing a PhD
it's really I notice how important it is
that the workspace is conducted for your
research so first of all I have kind of
two spaces I work at one is here in my
uh bedroom and the other one is at Uni
and at Uni I like to keep my workspace
as clean as possible that such that when
I arrive there I can just immediately
work and here I have it a little bit
more set up in a fun way but I think
it's good to experiment with what kind
of workspace works for you do you like a
little bit an Ambient sound on the
background do you like to work in a cafe
do you like to work in silence all by
yourself if in a quiet room and really
see it as a kind of experimentation
phase where you try different workspaces
and see how productive you are and also
try to be really honest with yourself so
for example I sometimes think I can work
quite well by myself in my room but
that's not really true I get really
distracted actually but I just find it
really comfortable working at home
another thing is to optimize your
digital workspace so for myself I create
kind of created in notion this digital
workspace for my PhD and I want to
distribute this soon such that other
people can also use it so if you sign up
to um the newsletter I'll distribute it
probably for free on there but in my
notion for example I have a word counter
because I found that really useful for
writing the PHD so every day I try to
finish about 500 Words which is about
one page but also I have other things in
there so for example when I'm reading
papers I collect papers on there when
I'm making notes I collect my notes on
there and I think having one digital
workspace as well that works really well
for you is also very important to build
that from the beginning finally a
technique that I use within the digital
workspace which so many people have
talked about but which has helped me a
lot is to have or to use a pomodora
timer and I do think I used the pomodora
timer in a little bit a different way
maybe I use just a standard a setting so
25 minutes and then maybe 5 to 10
minutes off but during those 5 or 10
minutes I actually work on another task
that is still kind of stimulating so I
don't really take a break because I kind
of noticed that if I take a true break
where watch some YouTube or whatever I
kind of get into that mindset and then I
find it really hard to get back to the
main task finally I think it's also nice
if you finish a writing session on a
high note this is also a small tip that
I got at a certain point but I find it
really good so if you're in the flow and
there's still a few things you can
finish I try to keep those things for
the next day such that the next day I
know immediately what I have to start on
how I have to start on this and I can
just kind of continue the working
session and I notice then you kind of
create the these Loops of being in the
zone from day to day section number four
this is kind of about morning routines
and evening routines I do think morning
routines are pretty uh personal if
you're not a morning person maybe this
will not resonate maybe this will not
resonate with you at all so then you can
skip this section but um I am a morning
personing so I noticed that when I wake
up a little bit on the earlier side I'm
a lot more productive that day but I've
also noticed it's a hard balance with
sleeping so expent with that yourself
but some things that I've tried to
experiment with lately is to try to
incorporate also exercise in my morning
and night routine so I like personally
to do weight training but also yoga cuz
yoga kind of help create a certain type
of focus that I found really useful
during the PHD so it kind of trains you
to use certain breathing techniques and
also certain meditation techniques that
for me really allowed me to also focus
better during studying days but I think
there are different types of of
meditation techniques that can also help
you with this so try to experiment with
that yeah and to be honest I think those
are kind of the only two things that I
really have to do so wake up early and
exercise at some point during the day
and all the other habits or techniques
even though I talked about it previously
on this channel as well actually for me
don't make that much of a difference I
don't need to journal in the morning I
don't need to have some kind of
elaborate morning routine to get started
I can actually just get up and straight
away start but if you do need a few
things to kind of get you in the flow or
kind of get you more in the studying
Zone try to experiment with that and try
to incorporate that in your morning
routine uh so lastly these are
motivation strategies I found motivation
always a bit a hard word because I think
motivation is kind of fleeting and once
you're motivated or not motivated it
shouldn't really matter for you studying
yes or no but I do think sometimes when
your motivation is really low it's
really hard to even start on a project
and that's these are tips for that so to
kind of just start working on something
and then sometimes you you kind of get
back into the zone and you can keep
working so one thing that I did during
my PhD especially is I uh developed
study specific playlists for every task
that I need to do and it sounds super
ridiculous but it actually works really
really well so I have um a playlist for
coding a playlist for writing and a
playlist for editing YouTube videos so
always when I code I put on the same
playlist and this is actually a really
yeah like deep house playlist so it
really makes time feel like it flows by
really really fast and also always when
I put it on my mind kind of goes like
okay it's coding time I need to be in
the coding mindset so try to experiment
with that as well your soundscape and
see if it works for you something
related to this is to try to identify
and replicate Focus triggers from past
successful studying sessions so I do
think for me music for example is this
kind of focus trigger so when a certain
type of music is playing it kind of
brings me back into that Focus but
knowing your own Focus triggers and
knowing what get you in the focus zone
so that when you think back on your week
for example what were the moments that
you were really focused what time of day
was it what were you doing what made you
so interested in the topic you were
focused on what was your environment
like and try to replicate these things
more and more such that you can get into
this Zone almost on command and
different Focus triggers can be for
example the environment you're in the
friends you're talking to the type of
subject you're working on and kind of
related to this but this is a small tip
is to have kind of all the essentials or
create a checklist of Essentials that
you need to get into this hyperfocused
zone so gather the things around you to
get into the hyperfocus mode AKA have
snacks around you minimize distraction
get your notebooks ready create a
checklist of all the items that should
be around you for you to finish a
project so for example when I'm filming
or writing I have all the gear already
set up the day before because I know if
I'm very unmotivated these small hurdles
can really make me stop doing anything
and not really work so I think having a
checklist of all the items that you
would like around you when you start a
study session is also a good tip so
these were all the study tips that
really worked for me and I do think they
seem very basic in some sense and very
simple and they're also very personal so
I think throughout studying I've learned
many techniques and many different ways
to focus but to be very honest now doing
a PhD I just realized a lot of them
don't really work I think they maybe
work for that individual person but not
for everyone so I think the biggest tip
that I can just give you with studying
is try to experiment what works for you
you know yourself best and you know when
you can focus or when you cannot focus
and this is probably a little bit
different for me and also different from
other people if you have any tips that
you would like to share that actually
really really works for you I would be
interested so put them down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye